hey guys i'm back welcome to another hd
tutorial in this video i'll be going
over a quick little bug fix that i
noticed in the cam studio screen
recorder and i'm just going to open it
up here and keep in mind i haven't
completely gotten this bug completely
fixed but this is a problem that exists
in camtasia studio six it is called
audio and video synchronization
sometimes if i click my mouse
it's not exactly synchronized with the
actual mouse clicking that you see so in
order to fix this you need to go to the
options like i showed you go to audio
options and go to audio and video
synchronization
click on it and the first option you
will see which is normally checked is do
not shift the audio or video streams but
in my case the audio actually goes
before the video by a little bit i hear
the words and before i see the mouth
movement mouse movements or also mouth
movements if i was doing a webcam
recording
so it's going to delay the video stream
by 1.58 seconds now that's a significant
difference guys 1.58 seconds is what
i've gotten it up to and it might
actually need more refining than that i
just wanted to show you guys how to fix
that audio and video synchronization
issue in camp in cam studio that does
not exist in camtasia studio six so guys
thanks for watching watching hd
hopefully and if you have any other
requests or bug fixes or tutorials that
you'd like me to do go ahead and
subscribe and i will do my best thanks
for watching peace